[Musique]
mon nom est Patrick Jean je suis
actuellement sur le tournage de pixel
qui adapté d'un courmétrage que j'ai
fait il y a 3 ans donc c'est vrai quand
on a mis le courtmétrage en ligne on a
fait 1 million je crois praement juste
une
[Musique]
nuit jeis très content du fait qu'on a
conservé le pitch de départ du film
pixel c'est à propos de je vidéo en le
monde et le gouvernement américain va
faire appel à 4 nerd qui ét des
champions de jeux vidéo dans les années
80 super acteur
[Musique]
comme vraiment des gens géux qui sont
très très investis dans le
projet et ensuite Colomb je pense que
c'est un choix qui est tout à fait
légitime dans le sens il a réalisé
beaucoup de film dans les années 80 on
Conn et bien s Harry
Potter l'idée de est venue quand j'étais
jeune je jou beaucoup à jeux vidé
là c'est vrai que pour moire sur le
tournage à ce moment c'éit comm dans le
je jeis malad sur les du jeu c'est
magique hy ludique et marrant cette idée
de jeu vidéo qui ene le monde donc voilà
je pense que c'est ça va toucher
beaucoup de
[Musique]
gens